- So I cupped my balls,
and I walked
with my knees together
to show that I was
from a good family.
And the guy goes,
hey, man, this is Ireland,
that happens all the time.
Shake it off, kid.
Walk with your dick out.
[dark electronic music]
♪ ♪
- Welcome to
"This Is Not Happening."
[chatter]
- [burps]
- I'm your host, Roy Wood, Jr.
Hey, there you go, boys.
Drink up.
Nobody's gonna remember what
the hell's happening tonight.
That dude's trying
to get my couch pregnant.
He peeing out the window.
- [retches]
- C'mon, man.
John Legend
bought me that piano.
[crowd cheers]
Who brought a ball pit?
- [screams]
[crowd gasps]
- [groans triumphantly]
[crowd cheers]
♪ ♪
- He is the host
of his podcast,
"Tom Rhodes Smart Camp,"
Tom Rhodes, you guys!
[electronic music]
[cheers and applause]
- I had a major transformation
in my life three years ago.
I don't know
if you can see this scar
I have on my forehead.
Uh, the lines that go
like that are wrinkles.
But this one is a scar.
I've been a heavy drinker and
heavy partier my whole life.
And three years ago,
I was so drunk in Philadelphia,
I blacked out
and fell off of a barstool
like a tree,
and busted my head open
on a tile floor.
And once my head hit
the ground,
I was wide awake.
And there was blood everywhere.
And some guy grabs my arm
and he lifts me up,
and he yells out to the bar,
we gotta call an ambulance!
I went, fuck that,
I don't have health insurance.
Don't you dare call
an ambulance.
He goes,
you gotta get to a hospital.
I'm like, how far is
the nearest hospital?
He goes, two blocks.
Two blocks and you were
gonna call an ambulance?
That's like $15,000, man.
So I got a wad of napkins
off the bar,
and I walked to the hospital.
And after I walked that first
block, I said to myself,
7,500.
But I have not drank
or done drugs
in three years, everybody.
And I want you to know--
I want you to know,
I want you to know the way I
used to feel about cocaine
is how I now
feel about donuts.
I mean, I won't go out
chasing after it,
but if a friend's got a bag,
I'll have a taste.
Mmm, maple bar.
Mmm-mmm.
So I was thinking about
times in my life
I was really fucked up.
Five years ago,
I was in Galway, Ireland.
And I was so drunk,
I woke up in
the middle of the night
in my hotel room
to go to the bathroom.
And I went into the bathroom,
and the door closed behind me.
But what had
actually happened was,
I was out in the hallway, and
I was locked out of my room.
And I don't know if any of you
have ever been naked and drunk,
and had to approach
the front desk for another key,
but I thought you should
show some humility, you know.
So I cupped my balls,
and I walked
with my knees together
to show that I was
from a good family.
Got to the front desk
and the guy goes,
hey, man, this is Ireland,
that happens all the time.
Shake it off, kid.
Walk with your dick out.
Be proud.
So I think the biggest blunder
that ever happened to me from
drinking was 15 years ago.
I was in Hong Kong doing shows.
And I stayed at
the Shangri-La Hotel,
the nicest hotel I have
ever stayed at in my life.
Beyond five-star.
Opulent luxury.
And I had never been
to Hong Kong before.
So the first day I was there,
I just walked and walked,
and soaked the city in
with my eyeballs.
And when I went back
to my hotel room
at the end of the day,
they had put a goldfish
in a little goldfish bowl,
in my room.
And there was a note next
to it, and it said,
"Traveling is sacred, but
no one deserves to be alone."
[crowd aww's, laughs]
That's why we provided
this friend, the goldfish,
to keep you company
during your stay here.
Two nights later, Fatboy Slim
is doing a concert on the
Kowloon side of the harbor.
I love Fatboy Slim.
I got tickets.
The audience was
the most beautiful,
fashionable Chinese people.
They looked like they had
fallen out of
fashion magazines.
And Fatboy Slim
was electrifying that night.
And I was just dancing with
all these beautiful people.
And I got really,
really drunk that night.
And somehow,
in the middle of the night,
back in my hotel room,
I shit the bed.
I was drunk and half asleep,
and I thought it was a fart.
And I blew it out,
and this wet-ass pee
went all over the bed.
And I was just shamed, man.
I had never shit a bed
before in my life.
Really, I felt terrible
about this.
So the next day
I left the hotel early,
without making eye-contact
with the housekeeping staff.
And I walked around
all afternoon.
And I went back to my hotel
room at the end of the day.
They had taken
my goldfish away.
[crowd aww's and laughs]
No one deserves to be alone,
except for you,
you creepy,
bed-shitting weirdo.
You know what's funny
about that
is that story happened to
me 15 years ago,
and I did not even tell
my closest friends.
And I damn sure wouldn't have
told that story on stage,
'cause I was single before.
Maybe I wanted to meet
a nice girl after the show,
and do a little [kissing].
Now I'm married.
I don't give a fuck.
I shit a bed, y'all.
Shit all over
that motherfucker.
You guys are great.
Thank you very much.
[cheers and applause]
- Tom Rhodes, everybody.